So number three for me, I went
with a very general thing,
but I do have some specifics.
It was our trip to Australia and Fiji.
That is my number one, okay.
So you have hit my number one.
Good, ha, ha, gotcha!
And it's that entire trip.
And it's so hard.
All of those moments are spectacular,
that you talked about,
and there's so many more.
I'll just shout out another
one, which is when we were
when we went on the day trip,
you actually weren't there.
The day trip outside of Sydney.
Thanks for reminding me.
And Lando had taken--
My son was sick.
We get off, we're like
taking some pictures,
this amazing overlook, and Lando's like,
Dad, how do you take a selfie?
And I'm like, well son,
you just take the phone,
and then you hit that button
so it turns around this way,
so you can see yourself,
and then you just take it.
And I'm giving it to him while he does it,
and Lando takes his first selfie.
So that's not the number
one moment of the year,
but it's a moment that encapsulates
the type of things that
you want to happen.
It's like, I ushered in
my son's first selfie
on an overlook in Australia.
Now I just, it's funny
that Lando's hesitancy
to take pictures, let
pictures be taken of himself,
led to him being eight
or however old he was,
before he took it.
Right, yes.
I got selfies of like,
non-talking Locke and Shepherd
like just like picking
up the camera and...
Because he refused to
have his picture taken.
And just taking pictures of themselves.
He wanted to be a ghost.
Now he welcomes pictures
being taken of him.
I mean, again, that's
another facet of that memory
is that he's changed and developed
in terms of his self-confidence.
That like there's all
these things wrapped up
into this goofy selfie that he took.
Where he's like,
he's got that funny
selfie look on his face.
So yeah, I mean, that whole thing,
that whole trip is my number one.
And it was just, man, we've carved out
time in 2019 for us to
have extended vacations.
And we're kinda earmarking
some of that time,
and trying to figure it out.
So I'm, it actually led to that.
Like, okay, we can, let's go big.
Well, I think.
I think carve out some time so that,
to create more of those.
Well, it shows you that,
I mean, first of all,
one of the great things about travel,
is because it shakes
up your normal routine,
it tends to be the thing that you remember
when you look back,
because it broke you
out of your day-to-day.
Right.
I even heard someone say,
man, this was on a podcast.
I'm sorry, I cannot remember who said it,
but it was great advice
that someone's dad said.
Giving financial advice.
That there's only a few things
you should go into debt for,
but one of those should be vacation.
So like don't, you can
justify going into debt
for a family vacation, which yeah,
the eyebrows raise a little bit, right?
But it's like--
Well that's a provocative thing to say.
It is.
And that's why he said it.
But the thing that I have
thought about this year is
when I think about what
I'm spending my money on.
It wasn't the only,
there was another thing.
I have thought that like, this feels,
if we're paying for a trip, for paying to,
I've got some exciting
stuff I'll talk about
later 'cause it's not happening time soon.
But paying for travel in my mind is,
I'm not gonna go into debt
for it, but it's justified.
I'm like, hmm, you look at the price tag,
but you're like yeah, but
I'm creating this memory.
So yeah, I think it's definitely.
I don't know what your number
one is, better be good.
Well, my number one is therapy.
Is that it?
Yeah.
Now therapy for me did not start in 2018.
It started the very,
very tail end of 2017.
Okay.
And I've talked about it a little bit.
But the thing, I mean, again,
I'm self-conscious
anytime I talk about it,
'cause I feel like it's one of those,
it's one of those really
LA things to talk about.
And I know that we're out
here in LA in this bubble
and you can kind of forget what
it feels like to not be here.
Yeah.
But, interestingly, I
would say that, again,
it's kind of very similar
to what I was talking about
earlier that, you know, you
change so significantly,
so quickly, when you're growing up.
And you're going through,
you think about how quickly our children
are changing as they grow up.
And like, we haven't changed that much.
You change in these dramatic ways,
both physically, but
your brain is changing,
and then the way you see
the world is changing.
And then even in your,
during your college time,
in your 20s, you're
experiencing these just changes.
In, even in your personality,
not fundamentally your personality,
but just different aspects.
And I kinda feel like in a lot of ways
up until I started kind
of exploring these things
with the help of a professional,
that I kind of just assumed I
was going to kinda just be me.
Just be the same guy.
Yeah, yeah.
For the rest of your life.
I'm like, I'm pretty healthy in general.
I mean, I originally went to therapy,
not because I thought that there
was something wrong with me
in terms of like the way that I see myself
or think about myself, I
went because of the stress,
what stress was doing to me.
The fact that I kinda let stress affect me
to the point that it was
affecting me physically.
And I was like, I just need
somebody to help me deal,
like kind of deal with this.
I got help with that.
But I think that the sort
of the breakthrough for me,
or the beginning of a breakthrough,
is when I started beginning to understand
why I am the way that I
am, like why my personality
is the way that I am, the way that it is.
Why I'm so independent, and why I can cry
while watching a commercial.
The "Lion King" trailer.
Like literally can, I started watching,
first of all, if you're not
watching "Dogs" on Netflix,
I don't know what you're doing.
You should watch "Dogs" on Netflix.
It's a documentary
series where they profile
a different dog and human
relationship in every one.
And I literally, the first episode,
started crying during the opening credits.
And then I just cried the
whole time every episode.
Is that when they're sacrificing cats,
like when the opening credits?
And speaking of cats, let
me just say right now,
you could not make this
documentary about cats.
Okay?
Hold on.
Now hold on, we're talking
about your therapy.
Let's get back to you.
You couldn't make it!
Don't deflect into the world of cat hate.
I, that was my fault.
In fact, I challenge you
to make a documentary
about the bond between cats and people,
and all the wonderful things these...
Watch "Dogs", and then tell me
that they could do the
same thing with cats.
They couldn't!
It's impossible!
Unless you're about to cry
let's bring it back to you.
I'm in therapy for
this, for my cat hatred.
But, it's interesting
because I cry really easily
at certain things like that.
But then if you ask me things about,
and I had a very, I had a great childhood,
I didn't experience like trauma.
And, but if you ask me
about things that like,
the most difficult things
that I experienced growing up
or whatever, I don't, there's no,
I don't experience, I don't, I won't cry.
I don't have sadness about those things.
But I can tell a story about
'em and make somebody else cry.
But yet, so I started
learning that, like I,
you got, your emotions have
to come out in some way.
And so for me, I had found
this way to kinda deal with 'em
by like I'm gonna watch
this documentary about dogs.
But yet not deal with
what's going on inside
and kind of, it's more locked up.
That's just kind of the
surface level talking about it.
But anyway, therapy has
been significant for me
because it represents
sort of the beginning of
a sort of a second journey in my life
of kinda going inside and
figuring some things out.
I feel like I'm at the
very beginning of that.
And there's a lot of work.
You hear people about talking
about the work that they're doing.
And then you start figuring out like, oh,
I need to be working
on myself in this way.
And it's not just about some
of the more obvious things,
which we've we've both been doing,
which is like getting
our schedule in order,
and making sure that we've
got things for the kids.
Which some of that has been
really assisted by therapy.
But the like, what is it about me?
How can I continue to grow?
And then how does that then affect
the relationships that I have?
How does that affect how,
what kind of father I am,
and what kind of husband I
am, what kind of friend I am?
So that's been, that's number one.
No specific moment.
I won't talk about it
like a moment in therapy
in which I had like a
breakthrough, I'll keep that to me.
That's your private list.
Between me and my therapist.
But therapy as a whole.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.